foreign
[Music]
OMG
we are live
good morning everyone
good morning
oh we're rolling deep today shouty
I'm trying not to yell my wife
right on the other side of the door
I'm trying to be
for a moment
is that all right
all right
yo yo we lied for shizzle
it's Akuma in the building Mary
d
oh D Aaron despiva
take credit for yourself for being alive
to be live in here amen
Bob Kirk
we've got Dino
I see Jerry
Bobby Jones
oh we rolling deep today shouty
Morris
all right
do you know say good morning right
Tenors yes good morning right Tenors
Aaron Des fever said right Tenors as
well
how fun
Connor Martin here Dennis Tooley
what's goody
I feel like I'm out of
a boat ride
then it said if I ever grow up I want to
be as cool as Joel oh
cool Dennis
cool fam
give yourself some credit fam
we about to jump into this
one second let me get set up here I'm a
little behind
um
ah
like that life's a little bright
oh and Mary said she can participate
today how fun
Earnest what up what up
there we go okay we're getting it back
together here people
Costa good morning
wow what's that
all right we're here
I'm a little behind today I didn't put
up my sign I didn't go naked ass
come over
what's up late last night
um recording a new
uh YouTube video which is very exciting
um
[Music]
I've been tracking the time
I've been um working on this one video
just to see if it's as crazy as I think
it is and so far
it has been
awesome
oh over 10 hours
on this one video incredible
so I appreciate all of y'all have been
to watch and support and share the
videos
I saw Jerry retweet my most recent one
which I greatly appreciate
just posted one about
um
Steve Harvey how he became
beginning of Comedy
it's very exciting
shit's doing well the fluffy one I just
posted is at like 80 000 views
great
very reassuring that all of this this
work is paying off
um
having a lot of fun doing the YouTube
channel it's certainly
started to uh
take over my life a bit
in a good way though
YouTube is a good
um employment opportunity
but Johnny come here for the YouTube tin
this is the right tank Club so
oh Dee said it's night for me very nice
Joyce is in the building it's Akuma
Scott said I usually can't participate
in this because I have to pick up my
daughter from school thankfully she is
sick today
[Laughter]
hilarious
well all right
well I think now
at um
I think now that it is officially like
10 15.
I think now we can start what do y'all
think I think now we can start
so
this is the right 10 Club everyone
welcome aboard
what
goody as we say here
and now
officially
thank you all for hanging out
and welcome officially
to the right tank Club here we go
everybody
word of the day is
we are the right 10 Club
there we go
[Applause]
yay
yay all right
so welcome to the right tin Club
everyone
oh and Mary said I love those how they'd
get their videos and feel like they'll
be a slow burn but useful for a long
time
long run info yes yeah that's true I do
need to remember that
just because not every video has 80 000
views doesn't mean that they won't but I
have learned that from the hot breath
YouTube channel that a lot of it it just
takes time
it just takes time
and I'm so grateful that y'all are
spending your valuable time
doing this fun right tank Club everyone
it just makes my heart smile
so I hope you're having a great day I
hope this helps make it a little bit
better
as what we do here
as we stream
what were you doing
[Music]
um what we're doing here every Wednesday
is we get a new word and write a new
joke
today the word of the day as you see it
up here
is credit
[Music]
so post your jokes in the live chat
using the word credit I'm about to write
a joke live using the word credit and um
let's hope for the best because my brain
is on tilt right now shouty we ain't all
the way there we ain't all we ain't all
the way up it's amazing
the value of sleep it's truly amazing
I can feel
a tremendous difference when I get
enough sleep and when I don't it's
incredible
um
so just something that we always
remember and keep in mind as we continue
to
be the best versions of ourselves
possible
which is the whole goal
oh Costa said my brain is always on tilt
so I feel you yeah big fact shouty big
facts
so this should be an interesting one
um because I don't know what's gonna
happen here
but
I do know that for the next 10 minutes
we're about to write a joke together
using the word credit so feel free as
I'm brainstorming feel free to ride
along with me feel free to
spitball ideas you have out there
um
but this will be an interesting one for
sure oh and Connor said sleep doesn't
get enough credit
agreed I totes agree my friend
and alas
we ain't sleeping we rotting fam so for
the next 10 minutes
let's get our writing screen up for the
next 10 minutes we are writing a joke
live using the word credit
good luck feel free to comment with your
ideas
and just know it's progress over
Perfection so this may or may not
this may or may not go
that's the disclaimer here but you're
gonna learn about the joke writing
process The Good the Bad and the bombing
so here we go
that was a laugh sound effect
all right
boom all right so the word of the day is
credit
I always like to start with some
brainstorming usually really for like
the first half I will um
brainstorm different things that come to
mind when I think of the word credit
like how Connor said sleep doesn't get
enough credit
um he used the word there very cleverly
hmm
credit card uh you know credit
card
debt and as you're brainstorming you
know you can brainstorm
common phrases with the word credit
associations of the word credit
makes you think of
credit card which makes you think of
student loans like you can take it all
the way to there as well
um debt you know and then maybe debt
makes you think of Interest
then it could be like debt bubble
you may also think of a like
the nation's debt and how that's in the
trillions
so right now we're literally just
brainstorming not trying to be funny not
trying to find a punch line right now
literally just getting ideas out of our
head and onto the page so that can be
with a random word like we do here or it
can be with an experience you had and oh
I think this could be a funny idea for a
joke okay we'll just start spitballing
the different ideas and different things
that come to mind when you hear this
word or you think of that memory or
experience you have
so credit card credit card debt you can
also do common phrases
give yourself some credit
credit which means like you know go easy
on yourself give yourself some credit
here you showed up and you're doing this
so regardless of the outcome just give
yourself some credit
for showing up
um
isn't there a phrase like I credit all
my success
success
to whatever
uh my wife
hard work
basically credit is being like I give
props
in this and this connotation I give
I give all the um accolades
so as we're um
two and a half minutes in here
still just kind of brainstorming
credit card and what else it doesn't
have to use the word uh credit
as you're brainstorming here you could
go to uh the opposite debit
maybe like debit card you know
like how people ask
creditor debit
street cred there we go Domingo yeah
that's a good one I can't believe I
missed that one dang fam
Street credit or street cred if you will
um
credit card
so you could also go into different
types of credit cards Amex
you know discover
[Music]
Visa those are always options as well
um
what are other kinds of cards as well
cards
Valentine
race card is something
um
street cred okay there could be
something with street cred and
um
pulled the race card
so just as we're uh college credit oh
yeah that's a good one Scott yeah
so really a joke that pops into my head
is
um
something about street cred and race
card so it could be to
could be
when I pulled
race card
in debt
Street Credit
so there could be something there oh
cash app Ernest said I owe you yeah yeah
um when I pulled the race card
in debt Street Credit
I got in debt with the street credit
oh that rhymes in debt with discrete
credit hey hey
[Music]
I created All My Success let's see
pulled the race card
all right
Ernest owes me
or he will get his black card revoked
oh we're over halfway there all right so
let's start formulating a joke here we
got some ideas out there we got credit
cards
street cred credit card debt debit cards
give all my credit to college credit
give yourself some credit
so which direction do I want to go here
I mean there's something to tell me and
there's usually when you're writing a
joke there's like something going on
in your Sixth Sense your sense of humor
that it's telling you oh there's
something funny here so I think
there could be something with
race card
and Street Credit so what now we need to
do is kind of start organizing this into
a joke what am I trying to say here
first off what is the premise of the
jokes basically the premise of the joke
is
maybe I'm
in debt
and uh Street Credit
basically
when I pulled the race car
but maybe it's the opposite so maybe the
punchline is race card and Street Credit
I've maxed out my street cred
Okay so
my street credit
is maxed
out
and then um I shouldn't
uh maybe
my race card has expired
all right let's work we're kind of on
the way to something here maybe um
uh
as a straight white man
my street credit is maxed out
my race card has expired okay here we go
okay
as a white dude
I get
no Street Credit
my race card
has expired
so now as we're brainstorming through
this we're kind of bouncing back and
forth between like race card there's
just some funny connection there so if
anyone has any ideas in the comments
feel free to share them as well
what I feel like it may go back the
other way now to where it's um
why dude I I get no Street Credit my
race card is expired
well people are laughing in the comments
at that one I feel like
ah okay
Sandy said race card was denied yeah or
it declined I guess because that's what
they would say
at like a grocery store or something oh
yeah declined
my race card declined
I don't hate that
I did
get
Street Credit
I wonder if it went the opposite way
um
my race card was declined I get no
Street Credit
I don't hate that
um as a white dude I get no Street
Credit my race card
declined
oh well
I thought that was a sound effect
there it is
oh oh nice all right we got some good
ones coming in here
see Evelyn just posted a joke hello
Evelyn
Smokey as well yeah we got some good
ones here
Scott it's hard to get Street Credit as
a white man because I say things like
Street Credit instead of street cred
or it could be like when I try because I
am a white dude so I don't have to say
as a white dude
so it could be um
yeah I don't hate that though
was declined all right so 10
I don't hate it as a white dude I get no
Street Credit my race card declined
and it could be like my weight my white
race card was declined
it could but for 10 minutes I don't hate
it
pretty good exercise there
thanks for hanging out nicely done
every Wednesday we do in this shouty so
pull up on the Wednesday live streams
here
nice
well I don't hate that one I gotta say
um
a lot of a lot of the times a lot of the
times it ain't it ain't all there but
that's not a bad joke there I don't hate
that one I'm gonna go post it
in our Facebook group
where we do a live voting
uh for joke of the day every day in
there
I don't love the wording of the joke but
I've for 10 minutes you know
I say we in there yeah yeah we in there
222.
so let me read your jokes
what you say
let me read it your jokes fam
so do post your jokes in the live chat
and I'll be happy to read them
Mary asked this month's contest theme uh
we're actually not doing a contest
so no worries
it's just like how can I submit if I
don't have Facebook no worries you don't
have to uh submit because we don't
we don't have a contest
well thanks for asking
all right well shall we read some of
your jokes here
um
ah
sleep bruh sleep
um
so let's jump into what is what
what is happening
there we go
all right Aaron just be the first joke
up
I try to get extra credit in school
extra credit
extra credit in school I got caught
stealing the principal's MasterCard
[Music]
I don't hate that at all that's a goody
there fan
nicely done yeah that's all there
where'd that sound effect go
I haven't done that sound effect in a
while Aaron but I gotta keep it a bean I
mean that's a good one there tried to
get extra credit in school I get caught
stealing my principal's MasterCard
it's a good way to kick this one off
baby
next joke
and for those of you just joining us
this is our weekly Wednesday live stream
where we have a random word and we write
a joke using that word and I'll read it
live on the air today's word is credit
you see scrolling across the screen
so post jeweled jokes
and Morris I credit all the people who
have had sex with me whatever my mom
pays them they deserve more
my heavenly day Morris
sounds like a confessional there
but I guess mother knows best huh
oh my gosh
Bobby said thank you for all the prayers
and well wishes hot breath I'm out of
the hospital breathing on my own and
headed to full recovery
love the hot breath Community for all
the positivity and Good Vibes oh my
heavens
well happy to hear that Bobby goodness
gracious didn't realize you weren't
breathing on your own oh heavens
I hope you're all right now
but I'm glad the community could be a
positive place for people
dang
she said they tried to put me on a
ventilator and I said that's not
happening I have to post hop breath word
of the day in the morning oh my gosh
you need a doctor's note there like Hey
doctor can you write a note for me
man
uh next joke we have Joan here
well I like getting credit for my work
cash
would be a lot better
yo I'm with it I mean
we I think we're two for two right now I
think we're two for two on that one I
don't do that sound effect often but
that's all there
love getting credit for my work cash
will be a lot better that's dope
thanks Joan
well done
uh dino
I can't take credit for my looks because
I owe it all to Krispy Kreme
Krispy Kreme
I can't take credit for my looks very
very funny there nicely done there Dino
um delicious
Krispy Kreme
oh
excuse me
that's good content there just oh
Connor Martin credit scores are some
bullish I already underachieved in
school and now you're telling me I'm
being great on how poor I
credit score
that's another good one
nice one there Connor nice use of the
word credit there
Morris I have a lot of credit issues my
boss never gives me any all right
nice use of credit there fam yo there's
a lot of good ones
some something in the air today I reckon
but there's a lot of good jokes popping
off today
um next joke
oh we had 35 peeps
welcome everyone to the right thing Club
the word of the day is credit if you
have a joke using that word do post it
in the live stream
you already missed me writing a joke
live but you can come back next
Wednesday
I do this every Wednesday at 10 A.M
um next joke on seeing here
Joyce Lyles I need a man with high
energy High test testosterone that's how
you know I have high testosterones I
can't even say it
I need a man with high energy high
testosterone and a high credit score
all right all right
nice little power of Threes there the
third one could be more surprising
um but use the word credit score there
and actually in hindsight you nailed it
Bravo there
Bravo there Joyce
um Bob
Kirk
Forks of Forks of the credit River where
two bodies of water come together is
like my love life dried up and
Meandering
oh
you could
um
get to the analogy quicker it's like my
love life is like Forks of the credit
River dried up in Meandering something
like that just to get to that analogy
quicker
well done there Bob oh
bubble
um
I'm not sure whose joke this is
politician
she
Dennis this is Dennis Tooley
I heard a politician say that approval
ratings aren't all that important see if
he thinks that when he's trying to buy a
car approval
oh is this two approval is credit and
politician
wait
why is this confusing
I heard a politician say that approval
ratings aren't all that important see if
he thinks that when he's trying to buy a
car
ah
approval is credit and politicians don't
care about their credit rating since
they just print more cash
okay all right all right all right
I see you there Dennis thanks for
sharing fam I see the analogy between
politicians getting credit and like a
credit rating there could be something
about corruption there as well but you
already did reference them printing cash
so yeah yeah
thanks for sharing fam
uh next joke I'm seeing here is Bobby
Sutton
if I want big laughs all I have to do is
hit the stage or fill out a credit
application in person
all right nice
well done there Bobby I like I like how
personal it is
um smokey
Augusta
they say give credit where credit is due
but give cash when credit is overdue
big facts
give credit where credit is due that's
another one
that's always fun about this exercise is
seeing how people use the random word to
make it their own another phrase we
didn't think of give credit when credit
is due nicely done there smoky
Nicole
uh tried to buy something with my credit
card the other day but I'm in so much
debt when I swiped it all I heard was
laughed
nice
very funny
let me see whose is this one
this is oh smokey did I read Smokies
well I already yeah I think I already
read this one yeah
ah
next joke
I'm seeing here ah yes Evelyn Medcalf my
mother taught me to never buy on credit
she also never gave me
ha
ha ha ha yo
the jokes today are bumping yo we got a
lot of good ones today nicely done there
Evelyn she also never gave me any that's
rich
killing with kindness right
hilarious
um next to Juke y'all
where are we at shouty
um
Mary Elizabeth
my first husband and I didn't work out
because we had too much in common we
both are attracted to men
to his credit he has better taste than
men than I do clearly oh nice nice tag
there too also using the word credit
nice
well done there Mary that's a fun one
uh
uh whose is this
I'm not sure who this is
my dad gave me the talk about scoring I
was confused what does credit have to do
with dating I left days
dateless and hating math
I'm not sure who this one is
but I see you fam
talk about scoring
what does credit have to do with dating
yeah I think um
I see the I see the Mr Right There
it's Michelle Van deusen okay dope yeah
I see the mystery there about scoring
meaning like hooking up but it was
actually about um like your credit score
I see you there Michelle very nice
thanks for sharing fam
um
they're nice uh the next
Pete
I can't believe they gave my cat a
credit card but at least that explains
all the fancy feasts all right
all right nice the Fancy Feast yeah yeah
John mulhill the teacher said I was a
real credit to the college's comedy
program which helps explain why I'm
forever in debt
nice
word play there John
Lori Milbourne I tried to purchase a
military-style vehicle the result my
credit score Tanked
oh that's a silly goose one well done
there Lori
Ernest on our YouTube channel said we
dealers have customers waiting for them
like credits after a Marvel movie
sounds like you're saying that from
personal experience
oh and Mary said
thank you so much I'm an open micro
starting out now I have something to
tell my improv class tonight thank you
so much Bobby for posting the live
stream oh
[Music]
yay
oh I love hearing that
welcome aboard Mary
Sandy Bernstein my fortune teller is
pretty sharp after she read my cards she
asked me to pay with cash
ah a
[Music]
oh it's so good yo I don't know who's
gonna win today these are so good
yeah these are good
I mean you know I don't want to just
throw them out there willy-nilly but
that one's all that too Sandy Bernstein
well done
uh Julie Drake I'm like a credit card I
give men zero interest for 90 days very
funny nice analogy
Mary Baker
I recently joined the gym they had an
incredible deal bring a friend get a
massage and get a fat girl coupon credit
for free pizza it was planted it was
Planet Fitness after all all right
noise recently joined the gym they had
incredible deal bring use the word
credit well done fat girl coupon credit
in a massage get a fat girl coupon
credit for free pizza
Planet Fitness maybe they should change
the name to Planet fatness
[Laughter]
that could be some word play to add
there though nicely done Mary
thanks for hanging out and getting to
participate today that's very exciting
uh Jeffrey Brandt my father taught me at
a young age that credit cards are for
needs not once therefore I use it to buy
beer lots of beer
all right credit cards are for needs not
once therefore I use it to buy beer lots
of beer yeah needs not once you need the
beer I see what you did there
I'll see what you did there
Jeffrey
glad you could make it even despite
drinking all that beer
George I almost ran outside of a
7-Eleven asked me meth or cash I was so
surprised by his honesty that I gave him
all the meth I am
nice mister right there
I'll see you there George
now I know why you could be up so early
today or thank you for getting up so
early despite not having any more meth
ha ha ha ha
um homie Dario good to see you fam
um
James Mackey
I had to use a paid toilet the other day
I asked if I could use it on credit
they're like nope pay as you go
pay as you go like going to the bathroom
nicely done there James
Bob gorelka
applying for credit card is like dating
I always get rejected
all right that's good Bob nice tight
analogy great word economy well done
there fam
and we have just a few more here my
friends so do
not forget to vote
in our Facebook group don't forget to go
vote for your favorite joke of the day
we will announce the winner here in just
a minute
we got Felix on our YouTube channel I
got such a bad score on my credit that I
had to go to summer school
my lawyers prefer to call it prison but
that's because they're not
oh nice nice use of the word credit
summer school my lawyers prefer to call
it prison
yeah well done there Felix that's a fun
one
micro when I was in college the only
thing that got rejected more than me was
my credit card oh yeah that's another
nice
nice tight joke there
well done there Mike yeah rejected
rejected dating rejected credit card
you remixed the word rejected there
nicely done
um
let me see yeah
back
and for those of you watching as well I
did just drop a new YouTube video I
think you'll really dig about
Steve Harvey
and if you haven't subscribed to my
personal YouTube channel definitely go
do that
creating a lot of fun video essays over
there
yeah there's a lot of good jokes today
goodness gracious
a lot of good jokes
it's Akuma you know the problem with
Street Credit we don't have the IRS and
legal audits if you let someone put it
on their tab you're gonna have to keep
tabs on it yourself or accept the losses
you put it on your tab or keep tabs
street cred yeah yeah
the IRS are legal audits Street Credit
the street credit you have to pay in
cash maybe something like that
Brian Smith I wonder if Joe Biden has
excellent credit he's had long enough to
work on it
you use the word credit but for like a
joke structure
you're trying to say that Joe Biden is
old so maybe something about his credit
um was you know
what's like a way to say his credit is
outdated
um
his credit is Medicare or something like
that you know
uh Ian Turner
I love giving credit where credit is due
that's why when my child messes up it's
my partner's mistake
that is hilarious
nicely done Ian
nicely done
credit man a lot of good jokes today
gotta give you all credit a lot of good
jokes today
Rector Nation I tried getting a loan
today they gave me an assignment for
extra credit file for bankruptcy
very nice
oh nice and it looks like we have a
winner today
street cred
uh
abanov said one common thing between my
hairline and credit card is both decline
hahaha
oh that's hilarious
DonTrell said good D was not on the
credit report that I got from the
background check before the first date
now I'm stuck
very nice credit report yeah yeah it's
like social credit score
oh and look at this Nicole Miller said
we need to give Joel more credit for all
the comedy work he has done helping us
all improve
oh thank you Nicole thank you Nicole yes
I will take any credit that y'all
um are happy to share cash app venmo
PayPal you know just just let your boy
know how you would like to
no it's all love
but um
yeah thank you so much Nicole I
appreciate you saying that and I
appreciate everyone who has shared the
credit
by sharing this show
it really helps this has been like our
busiest day one of our busiest ones yet
so that's great
let's keep this baby growing
yeah let's keep this show going onward
and upward oh and we have van Kerry here
I said to my friend Bill Arty
I can't lend you any money
he said why I said you have no cred up
Bill Lati no
very silly there man
oh my gosh look at all the love coming
in
oh my gosh
look at all the love coming in thank you
so much y'all
wow I really appreciate that
the words of affirmation go a long way
thank you so much
yay
and it looks like
um
Aaron despiva is today's winner
[Applause]
congratulations and look at this Bobby
said some of the highest voting tallies
in hoprat history everybody killed it
with the word today way to grow way to
grow comedians oh I love that
yes congratulations Aaron despiva 17
vote
well done congratulations to the OG
Aaron despiva appreciate you buddy try
to get extra credit in school I got
caught stealing the principal's
MasterCard
so good
this is great this was a good one today
too much love time to roast Joel
yes so y'all
appreciate all of y'all
so much for hanging out we do this every
single Wednesday
I love you all so much if y'all do want
to keep hanging out
go subscribe to my YouTube channel Mary
said I need a patreon I do I should
start a patreon
there is one for the podcast
um we started during the pandemic
and then we were like well what are we
doing there we kind of lost
lost Steam on it because you know you
don't want people to subscribe to
something at night get even more than
they expected out of it so
I need to figure out what I should do I
could do in my personal patreon perhaps
and it is such a good Community I
totally agree
zainova you are late but keep grinding
fam thanks for stopping in here at the
buzzer
um
Jeffrey Brandt said my business
partner's wife announced that she was
pregnant everyone is giving him all the
credit but like usual
behind closed doors I did oh
it's ridiculous dude
that's a funny misdirect though
oh Evelyn said dab lessons all right
all right
I don't hate it
I don't hate that at all
Aditya I got
I got mob last night all credits to The
mobber
all right all right all credit due
thank you Adit yeah thanks for sharing
fam
oh well all right let's land This Plane
I appreciate y'all for
hanging out I appreciate y'all for
spending your valuable time here with me
every Wednesday
and we'll be back next week my friends
but until then y'all have a good day and
oh wait a minute
wait a minute
not that Angel's on y'all that's what I
meant to do Angel's on y'all Angel's on
y'all y'all
bye bye y'all